le passé ne marche jamais
james le destin nous réunit à nouveau
à présent ton ennemi
il s'appelle sa fille lui qu'est-ce
qu'il veut se venger
moi dès que son secret remontera la
surface ça te tuera à coup sûr comprenez
que je veuille revenir dans la partie
il ya une jeune femme à santiago que
j'aimerais que tu rencontres vous êtes
en retard c'est quand vous voulez
salud
j'ai rencontré votre nouvelle double
zéro une jeune femme vraiment des arbres
je comprends que vous lui avait tiré
dessus
tout le monde a essayé au moins une fois
james bond
nous éradiquons des gens tous les deux
pour créer un monde meilleur mais moi je
sais d'être un peu plus méticuleux
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes vous encore
la ville haute et se forge
cette plus en plus dur de séparer le
bien du mal des méchants des héros de
nos jours
qu'est ce que c'est ils te rends pas
compte il va tuer des millions de gens
si on réussit pas
il n'y aura plus rien à sourire
[Musique]